أنت تعرف كل تلك الترميمات الفنية الفاشلة
في إسبانيا والتي دائمًا ما تكون
جيدة للضحك ،
تخيل جيدًا أنك الشخص الذي يتم
استعادته بعد
الاستيقاظ من قيلولة في مطار مينيابوليس
في الصباح الباكر ورؤية شابًا
جالسًا
مقابلك يبدأ في التحديق  أنا
وأرسم وأحدق في وجهي وأرسم ،
فأنا مثل هذا زاحف أم أن هذا
رائع ، قررت أنه كان رائعًا
، إيما كين البالغة من العمر ثمانية عشر عامًا كانت في
أول رحلة عبر البلاد بمفردها في
انتظار رحلة متصلة إلى لوس
أنجلوس
تعترف بأنها شعرت بالإطراء
وحتى أنها أعاقتها
للفنان الذي كنت أتخيله أنني كنت أتظاهر بعد
حوالي نصف ساعة اقترب الرجل
وقدم لي هذه
إيما تقول إنها كانت تأمل في
شيء على غرار
جاك تيتانيك أردت أن ترسمه  أنا معجب
بإحدى فتياتك الفرنسيات ، لكن بدلاً من ذلك ،
كنت أجذب مثل
شخصية ساوث بارك ، أخبرها الرجل الذي وقع على الرسم ،
أنني آسف إذا كان هذا غريبًا ،
لكنني
رسمتك على
الفور ، كنت مثل أوه
أوه ، واو حسنًا  نعم ولكن لمعجبيها
قالت ، يا إلهي ، شكرًا لك ، هذا رائع جدًا
منك ، لقد
قمت بعمل جيد ، تقول إيما التي تدرس
علم النفس وعلم الأعصاب أن الأمر
يشبه دعوة نابليون ديناميت
تريشيا للرقص
برسمها استغرق مني ثلاث ساعات حتى
تنتهي  التظليل على شفتك العليا
من عيون غاضبة تعترض إيما على
قناعها مرسومًا كما لو أنها لم تكن ترتديه على
أنفها عندما تقول إنها
شعرها الفوضوي وتلك النقطة من الجسد التي
شعرت بالتواضع لقد أمضوا 40 دقيقة في
الحديث من قبل  لقد غادرت رحلتهم إلى لوس أنجلوس
، انتهى به الأمر إلى أن يكون مثل صبي لطيف للغاية
منذ أن انتشر الرسم على نطاق
واسع ، تلقت إيما صورًا أخرى
للتعويض
والأصل تقشعر له الأبدان في
الثلاجة
، كانت فكرة والدي تعتقد
أنها هستيرية ربما كانت عملية
التقاط فاشلة  حيلة
لكنها على الأقل لا تستطيع الشكوى من
أنه لم يحصل على ماردها الجيد في
نيويورك